Marcelo mana is an environmentalist and
scholar and he is the former Minister of
Environment for Chile welcome Marcelo
hey doing windy thanks for a great of
course thank you so much for being with
us here today and you know before we
dive into the future of climate action
in Chile and beyond I think it would be
great for us to talk about sort of the
present and why Chile really represents
a country that is worth thinking about
when we talk about about climate you
know recently there have been lots of
commendable actions taken by your
country when we think about climate your
Chile recently committed to net zero
emissions by 2050 the first in the
Americas to do this and that's
especially notable when you think about
how much of Chile's economy really
depends on carbon emissions you know
mining and agriculture in spaces like
that
so could you start a little bit by just
talking about how how would this even be
possible to get to net zero emissions in
30 years and what would that what would
that mean for Chile mm-hmm it was a very
surreal image when we saw Minister Smith
the cop 25 president participe Nosa the
UN head on climate change with masks
having and delivering this new and DC
the important thing here is things that
are hard to build require consensus but
therefore to get rid of that consensus
the get rid of that commitment you need
to have another consensus and this
hasn't happened so the thing is the
reason why Chile has this sort of vision
towards mitigation that's ambitious is
that we see that there's a big economic
benefit we have seen we witnessed what
the renewable energy sector has been
able to do for investment for lowering
lowering energy cost and so therefore to
reach this goal we will inevitably
expand to 100% renewable but will also
transform our industry which is heavy on
fossil fuels towards low emissions with
the hydrogen economy kicking in with a
recently launched committee that I
formed the Minister Javad the Minister
of Energy
and also energy efficiency and a lot of
capture carbon capture we have we are
endowed with a lot of natural capital
taking care of that natural capital and
expanding plantations will allow us to
reach Net Zero by 2050 that's great I
mean and now it seems like Chile has
such a huge focus than in you know
thinking about renewable energy and
thinking about climate but this wasn't
always the case could you talk a little
bit I guess about the history of how
Chile arrived at this moment yeah so in
2011 2010 we had an energy discussion
with incumbents saying the only way we
could solve our energy problems will be
through large coal and large hydro in
the Patagonia and that really polarized
the discussion we got together as a
community after large protests that
triggered a lot of social movements and
we started discussing how we should be
able to do our energy going forward the
population public and rest set up almost
6,000 megawatts of coal-fired power
plants to never be built and when the
government official bachelors government
came in we pulled the plug on Hyder I
sent Project which is a big pride row
project in the Patagonia and both of
these conditions enabled an opportunity
for renewable energy you said in we put
in carbon taxes we put in environmental
regulations and we set up an energy
strategy that we did building on
discussing looking at the data in which
we thought that the 70 percent renewable
energy by 2050 was going to be a target
that we could agree on this target has
been long surpassed now we're thinking
of reaching that same goal by 2030 great
and you know I think and what you were
saying is about social protest that's
something that a lot of people who maybe
have been following news and what's
going on in Chile are familiar with
recent social protests and and I think
I'm curious about how you see that
factoring into climate action moving
forward how might these social protests
play a role in what climate action you
see and and really you know how is it
possible
fortunately to sort of be a leader in
climate action while also struggling
with some of these these social issues
well the social issues which are very
profound and important to address cause
for example cop 25 to not be able to be
held in Santiago to go to Madrid and
this also shifted a whole bunch of the
discussions and announcements that
weren't done and we were expecting to
have but regardless of this of the fact
that we have this commitment from from
the government today shows that there's
a resolution to continue forward but
really at the the model the economic
model of Chile was brought into into
question because the environmental
issues for example are widespread and
many times you have large coal-fired
power plants
being situated where people live and
with higher mortality rates you know
somebody lives where a power plant is
installed has twice the rate of death in
comparison to other people in Chile so
the model of having many people be
impacted for the benefit of few is
something that caused and triggered the
social unrest and it goes into the
economic model itself of extracting
polluting impacting communities and that
may not see the benefits of these
economic activities so while we've done
a lot we've come a long way for example
in securing a very emblematic agreement
to phase out coal fire power plants many
people feel that this wasn't done fast
enough and want this action be brought
faster and it sounds like having people
sort of be the voice and the the engine
behind making that happen is really been
part of this historical thread with
climate action in Chile and and it seems
like it would really sort of lead things
moving into the future
yes go ahead
we have a board we're gonna be you know
this is starting out we've we've we are
doing well but I think we need to double
down our commitments and so even though
we have ministries involved we have
civil society involved we need to bring
in the mainstream industry I think for
example the mining sector has a great
opportunity to be the solution for the
environmental issue
because we provide the copper the cobalt
the lithium that are required for solar
PV panels for for battery storage but we
need to do this in a clean manner I
think this is the biggest challenge
we're gonna have the next 20 years ahead
and you know sort of pivoting to the
pandemic and to thinking about what's
going on right now the entire world has
obviously been devastated by this crisis
you know what have been some of the
unique challenges that Chile has faced
and during this pandemic
well definitely as anybody we are always
struggling with in taking actions today
to prevent a deeper impact in the future
and we started off pretty pretty you
know pretty well we shut off schools we
shut off different cities and had
quarantine but we let off us we gave the
wrong signals to people and we didn't
have a consistent effort and this has
brought us to have the highest infection
rates per capita in the world these days
so this goes to show that we the same
parallel with climate change we need to
take action now to prevent deeper impact
later and I think we need to take the
lesson of this to continue with with an
effort because one thing is to announce
ambitious and DC another thing is to
invest and do the regulations you
require to turn this into reality but
there's some things that are interesting
the pollution in Santiago which is one
of the most polluted capitals
historically in Latin America has
dropped substantially the car related
emissions are down almost eighty to
ninety percent which is pretty
substantive and if we look at the
example of what's going on Harvard
University showed a study in which they
showed higher mortality rates for more
polluted cities and this is also the
case in Chile for every microgram of
pollution PM 2.5 there is an increase of
the fatality rate 9% but the thing is we
could also look back in what we've
achieved to now how do we not take him
measures to clean the air as we've done
so in Chile these last 20 years we
wouldn't be talking about five times
more people would have died from kovat
we have around 800 people but that have
died due to coal bed directly but this
had been much higher how do we not
taking action and in fact due to the
lower pollution which we estimate in
project
to the to them to the rest of the year
we will have saved as many lives
reducing the pollution as we have lost
in covent showing that there's a
pandemic that we also need to address
which is the crisis on air pollution
that suffocates many cities in the world
and and it seems like that's probably
something that we're seeing in other
areas around the world as you're as
you're suggesting with this air
pollution is a problem everywhere and
you know I'm curious also how these
challenges that you've mentioned and
maybe others might hinder or help some
of this progress that you're hoping to
make towards climate action you know
what what how do you see this factoring
into some of the decisions that might be
made going forward and in Chile and
beyond okay so we have a higher fatality
rates in more polluted cities and we
have a climate action to carry out
there's going to be a decisive decade in
which we need to lay the groundwork for
our lower emission strategies so
whatever we do today cannot lock us into
a incompatible climate future we need
you to lay the groundwork for this low
emissions transition so therefore a
green recovery efforts need to be done
as Chris Alena spoke last week has to be
related to a green recovery the creates
job immediately that addresses the
poverty issues that we have on energy
today in the southern chile and we need
to use this for expanding renewable
energy and expanding successful efforts
that we've done on electromobility today
we have the largest feast of electric
feats of electric buses outside of China
and but we could actually make this goal
even bigger because we've seen that the
reductions in cost have been almost 70
percent in comparison to diesel buses so
should use this opportunity to expand
and multiple stakeholders are working
we're working together to call on the
government to do a green recovery to use
the green bonds that we've already
issued and under which we've gotten
really low rates for fur for interest
rates to do and fund cleaning the air
clean the transportation and letting the
groundwork for a cleaner tomorrow in the
mining sector which is our biggest
challenge going forward
and then as far as the way that you sort
of think about and conceptualize climate
action you know have you have you
personally had any changes to your
thinking I'm just as a result of what
you're seeing through this pandemic yeah
I think we we start looking around
everybody had to struggle and find and
that we could do much more with less and
keeping a full economy that requires you
to buy a extra t-shirt that you don't
need the fact that we're using three
times more more more clothes than we
were maybe 20 years ago shows that we
are blowing up an economy that requires
us to destroy the environment in a way
to continue to forward and the food
system is going to be probably our
biggest challenge and I and you know
even though I've been working with
electric buses and with electromobility
and and just the more they the the more
conventional mitigation I think our
biggest cultural challenge will be to
talk about how our food decisions impact
the way that we you know the way that we
will have a future nature just put out a
report that showed something you know
when we're in the government what we we
talked about when Celia was good in
soccer we started going deeper into the
wintertime summer the the winter time
contest and we started winning games but
what to win those games we started doing
a lot of barbecues and the paper that
came out showed something that you know
when we when we explain this to people
that you guys are messing up the year
with barbecues people thought we were
crazy well nature now show the nature a
report shows that we actually fouled the
air and destroy the year and I live the
air because we wanted to celebrate the
soccer and we set this up to people and
people thought we were crazy now people
acknowledge the fact that the the basic
thing that you could do such as the way
that you choose how to cook could
actually impact your air so I think that
going forward at this cultural
challenges that we need to do we need to
tackle them head on we should need to
show the evidence otherwise we're just
going to be ignoring problems and
letting them perpetuate for the future
and you know for nations who have not
really prioritized climate in in the
same way that Chile has
are there lessons that you think can be
learned from some of the choices that
Chile has made in recent years that
other nations can apply or and how could
could folks in other countries implement
some of these strategies that you that
you've implemented in Chile so many
people in the US and across the world
know about the Chilean seabass the
Chilean sea bass is it was over fished
and almost collapsed one of the things
that we did under the support from
National Geographic and with the
leadership of President Bashir was to
expand marine protection from four
percent of our oceans to 43 percent
within one government which is a large
largest leap that there's only
comparison to the US during Obama in
terms of protection and this is because
we want this population also to recover
you know when you let the the park you
know stop fishing the overflow from the
fishing will actually increase the
biomass six-fold so I think you know one
of the efforts that we need to do as we
talk about the biodiversity convention
that's going to happen this next year is
that we need to change our relationship
to the environment we need to protect
and conserve our ecosystems so they
provide the services that they do they
do today today 96% of all mammals land
mammals arguments or stuff humans eat
only 4% of land mammals are wild when I
heard that data from National Geographic
for the first time I couldn't believe it
we've changed the relationship with the
planet
and we're suffering this decisions
because we see so Nordic diseases such
as corona virus spread time after time
and we have brewing here hi Bruno with a
question from having absolutely hello my
fellow there is no question from Melissa
Mahoney she asks if you can expand on
what deck anomic benefits of net zero
emissions are and especially could those
benefits be the same for Chile and for
other countries mm-hmm good for example
when I worked in the World Bank we
supported Chile to look into the macro
economic impacts of the net zero target
and it was shown that Chile will grow
four
Oh point four percent more so we turned
the risk of climate change and we turn
it into an opportunity of expanded
growth this manifests in lower
transportation costs lower energy cost
and this makes the economy more
competitive the cost of reaching the net
zero target outweigh us are much lower
than the benefits that we will have to
to reap and we're not even talking about
cleaner air benefits we're talking about
direct economic benefits of having
increased investments which is something
that every country will require these
years to recover from the kovat crisis
and lower energy cost so that's how it
manifests and and this is a consensus
today that we need to have more
renewable energy because this is the way
that we've had cleaner air and lower
energy costs there is another question
from someone in the audience asking
countries across Latin America I have
very different attitudes on climate can
you comment on that
so Pew Research Center has been putting
out reports regarding what is the main
external threat that you have and in
Europe and the US the biggest threat was
either China or Isis or some external
biblical threat in Latin America in
Africa its climate change number-one and
Chile is one of the highest with 86
percent of Chileans saying the crime
climate change is the greatest external
threat so this is also very high across
the region
we could have populist governments
coming in changing their priorities but
the reality is people are concerned
because they see the threat of climate
change every day and regardless of
whether the national government believes
in it climate change is real and is
causing impacts and causing poverty in
the region Thank You Vera back to your
way to me thank you thank you for
knowing and Marcel just you know one
last question before we actually say
goodbye which is just you know knowing
that you were involved in the
negotiations for the Paris agreement are
there things that you take from that
experience that you can apply to this
moment as we as we think about emerging
from this crime and coming out of the
Cova 19 endemic
yes that they're all there always be a
populist that will be opposing climate
action and the way to get at this is to
make the economic case so regardless of
what happens there will be an economic
case for spending on renewable energy
the u.s. grew it's in real energy
investments around 40 percent last year
in Brazil it grew almost 10 percent and
so therefore if we're able to align the
economic goals with climate goals you
will be able to make this go forward
there's a national the the network of
greening the financial system that puts
together central bankers the World Bank
launched a coalition a finance minister
for climate action these are great
efforts that will allow us to have the
financial system support climate action
because there's an economic benefit
because it's important for you for your
fiduciary responsibilities to disclose
the risk you're you have both
transitional and physical and if we're
able to do this regardless of what the
negotiations happen you know because
there always be there will always be
problems with the consensus you will
continue to have a resilient approach
because climate actually will continue
because you can have the economic system
support this that's really great thank
you so much Marcel for being with us to
share your perspective and your insight
it's really great to sort of zoom in on
some of the things happening in Chile
and and how that might apply to all of
us all over the world so thank you for
joining us today
thanks